hello everyone and welcome to new
adventures of Rick and Morty I mean me
and the morpheme now we already checked
out one game between the two of them
more if you wanted quite convincingly
then we had that a big chest party at
the st. Denis hotel where they were
being awesome and now the match
continues so first the three wins best
out of five let's see what happens here
Morphy with the white pieces opens with
E 4 and meek replies with a 6 the fringe
defense and this I know what you're
thinking this can only end well with d4
by Murphy and now g6 a variation you
will not see a lot today although it has
been used in in top level competition at
least the serve as a surprise for your
opponent Bishop to d3 we have disrupted
g7 and now Bishop to e3 developing the
the the bishops a morpheme wants to
develop the Knights via B 2 and E 2 and
then he wants the castle maybe push f4
and so on we have nice the e7 and here a
knife to e2 by Murphy and it's important
to note that this position has never
been reached again even though it's only
move 5 with b6 meek prepares the finger
to the light square bishop and now
Knight to d2 now with Bishop to b7 and
Morphy just castles and now d5 a
principled decision striking in the
center asking white do you want to allow
this capture which will free up my light
square bishop or do you want to block
the center with E 5 which is one more if
he did and now I can reply with c5 and
now in modern chess we will most likely
see c5 as it is what you want to do when
you play the fringe defense but hear me
decides the castle first he's gonna
prepare c5 first with the knight Knight
to d7 morphic continues with f4 and now
not allowing further expansion with
something like a g4 and f5 meek plays f5
himself which closes down the center
however it it creates this week east
exponent and the Murphy work will
definitely try to go after it with
something like a knight of 3 to g5 and
then to e6
so first Morphy goes for h3 he makes
room for Ace King he wants to play King
h2 up with g4 bring the rook over to G 1
if Morphy really respect
his opponent which I don't think he did
as I don't think more feel respected
anyone in terms of chess skill he'd
probably go for before and prevented
this c5 idea but as he saw that meek
wasn't interested in going c5 when he
had the chance he he probably thinks
that he's not interested in it now I saw
a bit of a bit of a twisted logic but if
you know if it works and if you take it
on your opponent faster that way why not
so h3 like I said preparing King h2 and
now Knight to d7 preparing c5 with King
to h2 by Murphy and only now c5 we have
C 3 strengthening the center also making
room for his bishop here and here
Mick has to decide whether he wants to
capture where he wants to keep the
tension with something like Knight to c6
or does he want to keep the center
closed with c4 and he goes for c4 now
the engine for example likes both c4 and
Knight to c6 like keeping the tension
and closing the center but to me a c4
feels very unnatural and I don't know
it's very unclear what's this light
square bishop will do for the rest of
the game and it seems like a very
non-human decision to me but okay we
have Bishop back to C - and now a six
week prepares b5 with Knight to f3 now
like we said e six is a week on more
fees going after a night of three he
wants to go g5 to e6 and now h6 straight
out preventing more fee at jump in with
the Knight to g5
although beef I was also a perfectly
perfectly good decision for example if
Knight g5 now you can go Queen b6
develop the Queen this way you keep an
eye on the pawn maybe prepare some
further expansion on the Queen side and
so on but okay h6 by meek and now g4
that everything is ready we have Quinta
h7 as meek is expecting more feet to
bring the rook to g1 he wants the
counter his rook with rook to g8 so the
King makes room for the rook we have
rook the g1 and now rook to g8
we have Quinta a1 now preparing Queen to
h4 which would be which would be very
nice
so Knights the c6 hear me regards the h4
square doesn't allow more fees Queenan
but he allows night the h4
and this is a what we talked about when
h6 was played by playing h6 you kind of
weakened the g6 pawn so maybe that b5
Queen b6 idea was a little bit better
and here it's already hard hard for me
to find a good move it's hard for him to
make use of his pieces the Knights here
the bishop the rook really not doing all
that much so and it's very hard to bring
them into the game Knight to the f8 it
is sort of an attempt but still it would
be a very hard game for me
he played Queen to f8 instead but now
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the best way to continue the attack
for Morphy well I'll give you a couple
of seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting the knight sacrifice and the
double check and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
it's Knight captures on g6 this only
makes sense
the Queen is under attack you have to
capture if you don't capture if you just
move the Queen then well there you've
just lost a very valuable pawn white
we'll just continue with the attack
you're dead lost here so you have to
take up the challenge but now in G
characters on f5 opening up a discovery
from the rook also there's a check from
the pawn so King of seven and now
captures an e6 with check if you don't
capture the pond then Morphy gains back
material so King e6 but now f5 with
check everything just falls in in place
if King if King goes to f7 then you can
just push the east exponent with check
pick up the knight that way so King the
e7 was played but now Murphy of course
doesn't want to allow the King to escape
the Queen side so Queen to h4 width
check King goes back to e 8 and now f6
and now again it's it's extremely hard
to find a good move here for me for
example if you try and keep to keep on
to everything for example Bishop date
rate then it's a bit of characters and
h6 attacks the Queen and after Queen
moves now east 6 is deadly because you
just open up the e-file you're
threatening to capture so you do have to
capture but now neither for attacks the
Queen and after the Queen moves now you
either bring the rook that you want with
check or you trade a pair of rooks and
then bring it to e1 with check and now
there's really not much to do here for
example King here f7 check just picks up
the Queen and all the other moves aren't
really
that much better so after f6 mix says
okay morphe you sacrificed a piece I'm
gonna sacrifice piece back and that way
I'm gonna survive the attack so he plays
a brush of character than f6 which is
always a principled idea when you're
under attack your opponent sacrificed
material if there is no other way you
should look for ways to give back
material and stabilize your position
maybe survive the attack so this is what
Mick is going for he captures an f6 and
now rook captures an g1 more fury
captures rook captures in g1 and now
Knight captures an f6 and the material
and the board is equal now both pairs 5
points pretty much the same material
however Mick has some problems with his
undeveloped Queen side so what do you do
here Murphy goes for Bishop to g6 check
so it seems
Mick survived the attack but not really
King to d7 and now Bishop back to F I
would check again not allowing the King
to run away to the Queen side because if
for example King c7 Bishop f4 check and
there's no escaping the bishop pair you
would have to go back and then again
it's a it's a very well it's a quick
death for black so after Bishop f5 check
King back to a eight and now Bishop
captures on h6
the queen is under attack you have to
move the Queen although you cannot leave
the defense of the night here you kind
of don't want to go something like Queen
to e7 then again Knight to f4 it's
coming rook to e1 is coming b1 square is
already covered everything is just
terrible for black here
quinta a trade was played just keeping
keeping an eye on the night but rook to
g7 now the black queen no longer defends
the night and here black has to make a
move although there aren't any good
moves here so hear me just play tonight
back to g8 but it was also in this
position that Alexander buffered me
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here it's actually a
force mate in 3 there are a few
different mate so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this forced mate
in 3 either of them so well I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on supporting either of them or both of
them better if it's both of them
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's just important to kick away
the King 2
fate so better up the g6 or d7 does the
job just the same for example a bunch of
checks King has to go to f8 and now
either rook f7 check or Queen to f2
check will do the job you have to do
something you cannot move the King
anywhere you have to block and then it's
just Queen captures and f6 mate and it's
the same if you don't if you if you
don't go here if you go here still the
King has to go to f8 and it's the exact
same a tonight blocks and Queen to f6
will now be made so yeah that's game
number two between Morphy and meek I
didn't find how long this game lasted
although I will double-check for the
next video so maybe I will be able to
find it we know that the previous one
game 1 ended in less than an hour but we
don't have that info on this one but
yeah Murphy takes game two and three
more games to go
or until Murphy wins one more game or if
Mika wants to win the match he has to
win the next three games in a row so
we'll see what happens but I think you
you do know what happens but yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Joseph compression
in Christopher Fernandez crash mats for
higher anonymous and the Michael
Hildebrand for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the Paul Morphy saga
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and everything else that
happens in the chess world well while
we're on the subject of what happens in
the chess world the World Chess
Championship will take place in Dubai it
is now it is now known and it will take
place I don't know if this is already
decided but probably in December and
they will move the world rapid embolus
championship from December to October so
they make room for the World Chess
Championship between Carson and his next
challenger in December so well I don't
think they've decided on everything
regarding the matter but when they do I
will keep you posted as usual so I thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent start of your week